Freak bitches of the faction that he
needed to become prime minister was by
guaranteeing them that he wouldn't move
too fast on gay marriage.
So it's a minority of a minority,
of concern of like culturally
conservative conservatives who represent
rural districts with a bunch of farmers
and the farmers,
you know,
it's always God damn farmers.
I had a joke,
one of my old specials.
There's only two types of people that
care about gay marriage.
People were really dumb,
or people that are secretly worry that
dicks are delicious.
I think that makes sense.
That's right.
Fucking farmers.
Someone's got to get them to suck a dick
and you realize,
what's the,
all the Hoopla about what about just go
ahead and suck it.
You probably wouldn't even like it.
And then you'd be like,
yeah,
this very guy.
I don't give a fuck.
What about the guy who was second oldest
whole sticks and um,
and a claw is that Seattle was,
he was dressed up in like leather and
he'd go out in the farm in the middle of
the night and he'd like give.
Whoa.
You're talking about the guy who got
arrested several times,
talking about the guy with died.
He died from getting.
His name was.
They used to call him Mr.
Hands.
I love that you know his name.
Yeah.
There was a documentary called zoo and
uh,
it was all about zoophilia,
which is a real sexual attraction that
people have to farm animals.
Always white people by the way.
[inaudible] hollow white people.
Yeah.
Actually,
I think the guy who got arrested was
black,
I think just covered in leather,
black leather bro.
He's from Australia.
It's also kind of adding insult to
injury for the animal that you're
actually wearing.
Leather.
You,
I'm wearing.
You're wearing your skin at the same
time as I.
Fuck you.
He's not wearing a horse here though.
Maybe not.
Yeah,
it's different.
It's different species,
but I'm this guy who lived in enough
claw.
They had found each other online on him
and the horse,
him and all these people,
they developed this relationship online
with these people that were really into
horses and getting fucked by farm
animals.
And so they invested in this property
and they got this farm and they had
these horses.
There was over 100 hours of footage of
these people getting fucked by animals.
And one guy,
they type it.
No,
there's a video of it.
You could watch it.
You want.
See?
Absolutely.
What else am I doing this afternoon?
And folks who are listening only I urge
you to go to youtube just to watch the
subtle twist of his head.
Absolutely mate.
I've been awakened Los Angeles.
I got a lot of time on my hands between
meetings.
They'll be a.
do you want to win the lottery?
Absolutely.
Ban and famous enough claw horse sex
faces.
New Charges in Tennessee.
Um,
oh,
it was a different guy.
What year is this?
Two thousand nine.
So after I'm.
That guy was dead.
It says,
okay.
Here it is.
A former Washington state man who was
convicted of at an enum cloth farm where
a man was fatally injured while having
sex with a horse in 2005.
Right.
Is accused of having sex with animals on
a Tennessee farm.
So one of the same people that was in
that group,
they're going to grow out of it.
Of course,
the way you're hardwired is the way
you're hardwired.
It's like,
I don't know about all that.
I would think the ones my friend got
fucked to death.
I might want to reconsider it.
So yeah,
you would think that sensible,
but it's.
I mean the thing is like being gay or
something,
I always get in trouble because when we
talk about pedophilia and stuff like
that,
I sort of make the same analogy,
which is I have.
I mean whilst it's the worst conceivable
thing that I can imagine anyone doing
morally,
I have some sympathy for people who are
hard wired in such a way that they get a
hard on from infants or animals or
something.
Right?
I mean the reason I'm not a pedophile is
not because I'm morally superior is
because I've never been attracted to a.
to anyone who's not post pubescent,
most likely you're right,
most likely you're right.
The real problem becomes in trying to
decipher what is causing some person to
have these feelings.
Like is it an instance of them being
molested themselves and they were
younger,
which is Mary.
It's disproportionately.
Yeah.
Is it the spectrum of a different ways
that the mind functions is so complex
and so confusing as to what's the origin
of these behavior patterns?
Is it because of abuse is because of a
malfunction?
Is it a,
is there a tumor?
Like what the fuck is going on in
someone's brain that leads them down
these paths and I don't think that's
been answered.
I know.
I mean what?
Look at the ticket back to be bestiality
and like having a,
giving a horse a blow job.
Like is there anything necessarily
unethical about giving a host of blow
job is the horse is pushing back?
I say no,
what if?
Yeah,
exactly.
So yeah,
if you offer up your butt to a horse and
he's.
And he's just digging in there.
He just shook his head.
I'm telling you though,
like what is morally,
what is actually morally wrong with
fucking a horse?
If the horse is into it?
Well the horse fucks you.
First of all the horses is a top.
Um,
the,
the video of the guy getting fucked to
death by the horse though is horrific of
course available.
How was he not able to get out of this
situation?
But the horse out of pin.
Those are the video starts out.
A buddy of mine sent this to me.
This one I watched it 100 times,
Bro.
On my computer right now.
The screensaver.
It's sitting there.
I just copy it.
I put it on little flash drives leaving
around my house just in case somebody
decides to delete it off the Internet.
I'm the guy.
It's the video starts out and the guy is
naked and he's bent over bale of Hay and
then his friend,
I use air quotes,
grabs the horses penis and leads it up
to his butt.
And you're like,
there is no fucking way.
And then what does that even happen?
How?
Like what kind of what?
No,
he's up on his laptop.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Here we go.
Don't be scared.
Homey.com.
What do you mean how,
I mean the guy,
just a giant.
But it's really that simple.
Yeah.
Well,
no,
I mean I know that like you gotta like
you gotTa Lube up a little bit
beforehand,
you're going to make sure that you're
available,
but that's a lot.
That's a lot of fingers.
You've got to put it in before the horse
can go.
Yeah,
there's a lot going on there.
It's not that simple.
Um,
it's again,
it's one of those things like,
what the fuck is it about a person's
mind that allows that in there?
Yeah.
Why?
What,
and how do you get from A.
I think this would be an amazing thing
to try to actually being there in the
band.
I like straddled over the bale of Hay.
I don't know how you,
I'd be too.
I'd be too bashful.
Even if I wanted to do it,
I'll be too.
It's adorable.
I wouldn't have the guts,
I think,
uh,
I mean obviously I'm just thinking what
the fuck do I know?
But don't pretend you never horse
walker.
I think there's,
there's just,
look,
there's a reason why some people love
jazz music and there's some people that
love basketball and some people like
sailing,
some people hate the water and some
people want to sunbathe all day and some
people want to only go out at night and
we're plucking people vary a lot and in
this gigantic broad variance of human
beings every now and then put one
pressure cooker spits out a doodle.
Let's get fucked by horses.
What I mean,
yeah,
I totally take that,
but what I mean is I'm amazed at the,
at the people who can,
who can translate their latent mental
desires into actual real world
experiences,
whether that's climbing Mount Everest.
I mean,
there was all kinds of things I'd like
to do.
Joe's eyes just getting real life as he
looks at something on his laptop.
I'm trying to find Mr.
I found it,
Mr.
whether it's a.
I'd like to go scuba diving with sharks.
I'd like to go,
uh,
you know,
I'd like to go scuba diving under
Antarctic ice,
but I haven't done it because I'm too
much of a pussy and I'm too much of a
pussy to get raped by a horse.
That's what I'm saying,
dude.
It's not my thing.
I don't get it.
Why it?
In the meantime,
I'm going to plug my podcast,
which is a,
which people should go and check out
weight.
The people alive.
We have paypal as well.
One word and you can find it on the.
We basically get three interesting
people in a bar and we all talk about
that.
What's going on in the world?
Jim Norton,
Artie Lange,
beautiful.
Looks like that.
Great.
Well,
New York's a good spot to do that.
A lot of opinionated people.
Yeah,
it's fantastic.
We did one here as well with Greg
Fitzsimmons and uh,
Fred's dollar,
Anzac craiger funny people and Joe was
on it as well.
If you want to check out episode 30
episodes,
30 Joe Rogan bars that,
uh,
that particular one is pine box rock
shop,
which is where we used to do it.
That was in,
it was great.
That place looks awesome and now we do
it in Williamsburg.
Oh,
of course you do.
How dare quick do you have to roll up
the.
The cops of your pants?
It wouldn't be a tide.
It'd be like a bow tie,
but yeah,
like done Sinatra style.
I'm tucked or exactly around my neck and
he found the video.
I want to say something funny.
Here it is.
I don't.
Do I want to say this?
I'm not gonna be able to undo this.
Am I going to able to unsee this?
Will make sure that he doesn't.
It doesn't get shown on screen.
Jamie,
starring Mr Han's.
So here's the gentlemen.
Okay.
There's a little dark.
It looks like a night vision type thing
because the guys lifting the at the
front legs are on his shoulders.
No,
no.
The horse's front legs are on the Hay
and see the horses Dick.
And it's,
hey,
look at this seeing this dare he cued up
and the guy's having a hard time getting
it right.
And how about that?
And it goes all the way and is that one
lives in test on the phone,
son?
Yeah.
He died.
What sounds?
Do you hear the sound?
Yes.
And now the Dick comes out and it's got
liquid all over it,
which is probably like,
oh,
is that what it was?
Yeah.
I can't look anymore.
What if I go to jail for having that?
Like it's totally illegal.
I'm like,
I'm feeling I'm feeling a little
violated.
Should a guy died that way.
I just saw him in dying from a Dick
Eighty minutes ago.
I pulled into the car park here on a
beautiful California day and if you'd
told me then that in 80 minutes time I
would have just watched a man die from
being anal.
He raped by a horse.
How about the sound he makes?
I wouldn't have believed you when I hear
the sound again.
No,
I don't want to hear the sound again.
Joe.
A sound pleasant conversation is
pleasant.
What about health and happiness?
We should be happy.
Would you be happy?
We figured out a way to not have this
happen to us.
Yeah.
It's pretty easy to.
Not have that happen to you there.
There are so many things that have to
happen in order for that to happen.
Okay?
Hear that.
That's the moment in which,
uh,
which,
horses penis goes through his intestine
and into his head.
That's called.
That's a wrap.
That's a wrap for this life.
Folks.
Take care of.
We're seeing the next dimension,
Gilis fucking way to die.
The Darwin awards.
There's one who may be awesome.
Maybe it's better than being in a
nursing home and having some guy kick
you.
Isn't there anything in between that
allows my only two options?
Either they get to Beta nursing home and
somebody kicked me.
I get to get mainly raped to death by a
horse.
That's it.
Gender options,
but I mean,
listen,
my point of view is that this guy in
getting fucked to death by a horse
created this video and this video has
provided me with hundreds of hours of
entertainment that I would have never
gotten without.
This guy dies of als has only one minute
long.
If you have 100 times.
I've watched it so many times,
I'm exaggerating,
but think about all the people
throughout the world who will now Google
Mr Han's find that video.
I'm sure it's up there somewhere.
[inaudible] laugh their fucking ass off.
Like that guy probably gave all those
people a burst of happiness like through
his death.
Like you think about like what you've
done in life and what having those
experiences and showing them to other
people,
what impact it has on them.
How many people have watched people do
those?
Those bird suits.
The squirrel suits.
They jump off buildings and shit and
they fly around and you watch me get a
thrill out of it.
Like,
whoa.
You watch those videos.
You get a thrill out of that,
right?
You watch a guy bungee jumping and get a
thrill.
Yeah.
Watch this and millions of people.
Sure.
I think.
I think it.
Does that make you happy?
The same way that the birdman videos
make you happy?
Yes.
There's a difference here at dude dies
getting anal.
He raped by a horse.
Bird guys die all the time.
Yeah.
I wouldn't want to say one way that
trees and shit motherfuckers.
See,
that's what I'm talking about.
This is a humble board on the edge of
the road,
on the edge of the top of us guys.
These guys are spinning around on one of
these.
First of all,
you're counting on these Chinese lithium
ion batteries.
They were put together by slaves.
Who knows if they're going to burst into
flames.
This guy's doing handstands.
He's doing fucking handstands on top of
a skyscraper.
Cool.
What does that Dubai.
Where is he?
It looks like to fly.
No,
he's perfect example,
if you saw that,
like that gives you a thrill,
but if one of those guys did that and
then when flying off the building like
that,
I wouldn't like what if Mr.
Hands.
That was a video where he lived because
he got fucked to death.
A gang.
I mean get fucked a gang at times where
you get fucked to death.
I'd be.
I'd be happier.
I'd be happier if he lived,
but then I wouldn't know.
I also wouldn't be happy about that.
I'm just enjoying the entire Mr Han's
experience.
Joe Rogan.
But what if you met him and then he was
annoying you bucket wish that guy got
fucked to death.
It's probably would be.
Did you hear?
Did you hear that Oklahoma has had to
change there.
I was just looking.